salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliarvi un canale e
il canale di ore di terrore un ragazzo
veramente molto molto bravo che
recensisce film horror classici o poco
conosciuti comunque è veramente molto
talentuoso ha fatto poche recensioni
sembra 45 ma basta vederne anche solo
una per vedere che effettivamente ne sa
ne sa tantissimo quindi se vi piace
iscrivetevi e ditegli che vi ho mandato
io
detto questo iniziamo e la recensione di
oggi e su un film
questo film el avete consigliato in 48
miliardi e 937 milioni ma solo uno è
riuscito a trovarlo per farmelo guardare
victor l'asl 88 non ti ho mai odiato
così tanto in vita mia
il film in questione è metal men è un
film del
2008 e diretto da ron car cosca che
sicuramente vi ricorderete per finti po
un
nome talmente il primo film che ha
diretto ed infine stupido stupido
stupido stupido stupido vedere per
credere
numero 5
la trama questa mela sbrigo la veloce
anche perché non c'è molto da dire
la trama è un professore progetta una
tuta iper tecnologica il cattivone di
turno al lavoro rubare per credo
conquistare il mondo allora il
professore prende uno dei suoi studenti
migliori e gliela fa indossare per non
farla rubare al cattivone di turno come
vedete si discosta abbastanza da film di
iron man
soprattutto per la tuta sembra uno di
quei costumi dei power ranger di
carnevale per i bambini ma il bello deve
ancora venire
numero 4 l'azione meno mettiamo però
subito le mani avanti e ci sono certi
film squallidi che per quanto alla regia
sia putrida e la recitazione sia ai
livelli di quelli risotto alle erbette
devo dire che alcune volte le scene
d'azione sono abbastanza decenti e in
questo film abbiamo una tuta che per
quanto faccia schifo da vedere e super
tecnologica fateci vedere qualche
sparatoria
o bene quindi indossando la tuta il
protagonista impara le arti marziali
non importa vediamo altro
ok altre arti marziali dei fatti ci
vedere qualche sparatoria
ok
ho capito sa fare le arti marziali basta
fargli fare qualcos'altro è una tuta
super tecnologica saprà fare qualcosa
saprà sparare qualcosa io e aspettavo
degli effetti speciali brutti di
sparatorie missili volo qualcosa no no
no in tutto finì in un'ora e mezza di
film non spara quasi neanche un colpo
tutti i combattimenti che ci sono
dall'inizio alla fine di questo dannato
film sono tutti gli arti marziali ma mi
spieghi che cazzo servono le scene di
arti marziali o comunque a mani nude
qualora indosso una tuta di metallo così
trasformi veramente questo film in un
enorme puntata dei power rangers
[Musica]
ma il problema sta alla base
numero 3 la quali sono secondo voi i
poteri che potrebbe avere un armatura
iper tecnologica io avrei detto spara
dai polsi da dal petto che ne so tipo
mac giapponese o laser dagli occhi
missili ovunque lance coltelli o gli
escono delle lave no
le abilità che il professore ha messo in
questa armatura sono a dir poco casuali
e come se tu crearsi un personaggio di
un gioco di ruolo lec mettessi poteri un
po del fuoco un po del ghiaccio e un po
di teletrasporto un po di meditazione un
po di soldato un po di ibert a caso fai
un miscuglio generale prendendo però i
più inutili per esempio l'armatura
all'abilità di far cambiare faccia a chi
le indossa può essere utile ma perché
farci un'inter armatura quando poi canti
soltanto faccia e quante volte la usa
per stabilità al protagonista che lavora
sola poi c'è l'abilità di curare
passando con la mano sopra una ferita
alla ferita scompare totalmente non è
che si cicatrizzano scompare totalmente
come se non fosse mai esistita di nuovo
ok ma è casuale c'è il fatto che sicuri
il fatto che si trasforma difatti è
casuale e quante volte la userà
l'abilità il protagonista di film una
volta sola poi ha l'abilità di farti
diventare invisibile e quante volte la
userà il protagonista questa grande
abilità che una volta sola il film
potrebbe finire in 5 secondi lui diventa
visibile entra nella stanza del cattivo
l'italia la testa e se ne va via no non
è abbastanza furbo protagonista o gli
scrittori e il team non sono abbastanza
furbi quindi è inconsistente da far
schifo poi ha l'abilità di generare uno
scudo anti proiettile
vabbé ma quel che abilitando attacco
cela un super difesa cosa vuole rubare a
fare il nemico se si difende poi solo
con questa cavolo di armatura in realtà
qualcosa lancia infatti alla fine del
film dopo un'ora e mezza di tortura
spara un dannatissimo missile uno solo e
indovinate come l'hanno reso
[Musica]
di merda tubi su tutto stupido perché la
vita sono presi completamente a caso lui
sa le arti marziali solo perché mette la
tuta può diventare invisibile può
generare uno scudo che può curare con le
mani può fare le cose di gesù ma non può
attaccare e sparare proiettili
però non ha neanche un abilità di
movimento che non c'è una vita che lo fa
correre più veloce debba far uscire
tattili da sotto il novantenne tipo
l'ispettore gadget own un elicottero
dalla testa o volare per esempio visto
che sembra una parodia di iron man iron
man volava perchè non lo fai volare noi
dobbiamo assistere a scene patetiche
come questa lui che guida con l'armatura
guida con l'armatura
dic torna slow fatti i cazzi tuoi la
prossima volta
numero 2 il finale il finale si vede il
cattivone che mette una maschera addosso
alla protagonista e le diventa in
qualche modo anche lei tipo forte perché
ha solo la maschera in testa perché è
fatta con nanoparticelle che vanno
dentro la la tua testa l'hanno spiegato
malissimo quindi non me lo so ripetere e
in più crea un altro home nemico fatto
con l'armatura e quindi c'è lo scontro
tra il protagonista e il robot il cyborg
del nemico scontro finale una schifezza
inimmaginabile ma io lo sapevo già il
protagonista sconfigge il robot è lui
con la ragazza lui con armatura la
ragazza solo col casco dell'armatura e
vissero felici e contenti finisce il
film partono i titoli di coda e si vede
un quadratino dove ci sono delle
immagini di repertorio credo noi si vede
l'armatura volare
[Musica]
ma vi prende per il culo nei titoli di
coda fai volare l'armatura ma perché mi
devi far innervosire così perché devi
mettermi le immagini dove c'è
effettivamente un armatura [ __ ]
alla fine del film nei crediti finale
cosa mi rappresenta cosa vuoi dirmi che
che potevi farlo ma non l'hai fatto
perché non ci avevi voglia di malo
dimmelo e poi dopo i titoli di coda c'è
un altro finale c'è il finale dove beppe
batte il coso poi ci sono i titoli di
coda con la stronzata della dalla natura
che vola e poi un altro finale non è
diverso e che pur continuo si vede tv 23
10 anni dopo non mi ricordo perché
votato così incasinato così stupido e
stupido perché devi fieri e sul cervello
dello spettatore che già spappolato dopo
la visione dell'intero film e vai a
finirlo così così incasinato non lo so è
proprio stupida stupida e senza senso
questa cosa qui
numero uno la logica del professore
tutti i problemi che ho descritto fino
adesso non fanno parte delle degli
effetti speciali degli attori della
recitazione no è soltanto sono soltanto
gli scrittori gli scrittori che si
immaginano
al potere di curare il potere di creare
uno scudo per un uso una volta è colpa
degli scrittori io voglio raccontarvi e
riassumervi i primi dieci minuti i film
il protagonista studia bilogia e grazie
a questo inizia a creare un videogame
perché boh non si sa voi non adorate di
film quando fanno vedere qualcuno che
sta videogiocando ma tipo sta giocando a
delle presentazioni e pg e tasti così
chicca la tastiera a caso quando sullo
schermo non c'è nulla io sì andando
avanti il ragazzo studia bilogia e crea
un videogame e grazie a questo il
professore lo ingaggia per testare la
tuta lo ingaggia perché lui ha
progettato un videogame per che studia
biologia bisogna essere chiari tanto non
hanno senso tutte e due le risposte
quindi il professore sa che sta per
arrivare il nemico di turno che vuole
rubare l'armatura ma non lo dice al
ragazzo però vuole nasconderla questa
armatura allora dice al ragazzo facciamo
un esperimento ti chiudi in una cella
frigorifera per testare alcune cose così
mentre ragazze nella cella frigorifera
arriva al nemico non trova la natura e
se ne va il professori chiude il ragazzo
nella cella frigorifera per fare il
finto test a meno 40 gradi ma cosa fai
ma quel ragazzo muore dentro vabbe che
la tuta ed era per testarla tra
virgolette ma perché mettano a meno 40
gradi infatti poi quando si riapre la
porta lui e è riverso per terra mezzo
congelato ma scusate ma non poteva
mettere soltanto l'armatura dentro la
cella frigorifera senza chiamare il
ragazzo per indossarla e farlo andare
dentro metteva i pezzi chiudeva la cella
frigorifera arrivare nemico non la trova
e se ne andava via perché usare il
ragazzo soprattutto se
una volta indossata l'armatura non si
può più togliere professore ma che cazzo
fai ai bloccato una persona dentro la
natura per sempre e soltanto per
nasconderla degli amici perché non si
può togliere tra i poteri che non vi ho
detto prima dell'armatura perché non
volevo dirvelo la l'armatura la capacità
di diventare c'è di far diventare
invisibile l'armatura certi fatti fa
vedere la persona ma la natura diventa
invisibile ma diventa invisibile non è
che scompare certo costruisce un
armatore che ha la tecnologia di
diventare invisibile di farti diventare
invisibile di farti cambiare faccia di
curare il mondo di sparare missili ma
non riesce a cos'è loro un congegno che
te la faccio a togliere perché perché
questa tortura psicologica perché io lo
so che usiamo soltanto il 2 per cento
del nostro cervello ma cazzo un sano
decentemente col 2 per cento e come se
non bastasse poi vado a cercare su
internet e trovo roba bay che potrei
parlare di questa recensione per 20 ore
andiamo a vedere tutta la gente che ha
lavorato su questo film tra virgolette
andiamo a vedere sotto la voce effetti
speciali e già mi stupisce che ci sia
una voce chiamate effetti speciali e si
può vedere che sono tre le persone che
hanno lavorato sugli effetti speciali 3
ma su cosa hanno lavorato se tre persone
perché probabilmente durante l'arco di
tempo è stato fatto il film la gente si
suicidava prendeva lo uno degli effetti
speciali si sparava in bocca a metà film
ne prendeva non altro si sparava in
bocca alla fine del film allora vi
prendiamo un terzo per dire abbiamo tre
così degli effetti speciali
questo film è
stupido stupido non ha senso
inconsistente è tutto sbagliato
questo punto meglio somme di su good
almeno ti fai due risate e se ve lo
state chiedendo si vendono questo film
non è una roba amatoriale è tenuta in
una videocassetta del 1980 lo vendono
perché sono andato a leggere in giro e
c'è molta gente che si lamenta proprio
di questo che vengano questi film allo
stesso prezzo dei film normali diciamo
normali perché questi sono quei film
speciali vado a vomitare torno subito